tutu what are you doing
[Music]
dad yeah well you've got it on your face
yeah
welcome to tutus pumpkin patch wow can i
see your hands true
to the soap on their hands
ball is officially here and on saturday
khloe kardashian
and tristan thompson brought in the new
season
by throwing a pumpkin party for their
two-year-old daughter
true be careful with the eyes
oh my goodness true and her two-year-old
cousin chicago
took the party to the next level by
painting each other's faces
in this adorable video kim and kanye's
youngest son
song also joined in on the festivities
with his big sister
chloe summed up the fun by captioning
the post quote
family pumpkin carving day dad
yeah well you got it on your face yeah
a source told et in august that chloe
and tristan were officially back
together
saying quote things with chloe and
tristan have been great
and the couple is taking this time in
quarantine
to really reconnect and enjoy one
another all of this comes after chloe
and tristan previously split
in 2019 after tristan was caught in two
separate cheating scandals
one just days before true's birth in
2018
and the other with kylie jenner's former
bestie
jordan woods one of my fears is you're
acting like this until you get what you
want and then if you do
you're going to turn into like the old
tristan again the couple's journey
towards trying to rekindle their
relationship has started playing out on
the latest season of keeping up with the
kardashians
and true's pumpkin patch party is the
latest evidence
that things seem to be working out
between the two
to the show wow
in 2019 chloe opened up to e.t
about how motherhood puts the hard times
in life
into perspective it's just like no
matter how tired you are
whatever you just it's complete bliss
and like
no matter what and no matter just i mean
christmas day i was so hungover
and i was like how am i going to get
through this day and just when you see
your baby and how happy and like you
just get through it and i was like okay
if i
could do anything i could do this and
it's just the best and just the love
that you get
that you also get to give and receive
it's just it's beautiful
there's something about seeing the world
again
through a little baby's eyes yeah
i think it really makes you know our
lives they get busy and things get heavy
and then to see like the innocence of a
child i just always like
i think also motherhood just puts life
into perspective and what's important to
you and
and i still think people who don't have
kids there's definitely there's things
that are important to them too because i
felt that way
but i think you just re-evaluate things
like i don't want to do that tonight and
it's okay to say no so i can spend time
with my family